I've already got my generator set up, and I imported java.util.Random. I know
exactly how many times I want to generate a random number, so I'll use a for
loop. I want it to generate 100 numbers, and I want to generate numbers between
one and six. If I use it this way, it'll give me numbers 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, and 5.
So I have to add one. Now I have a die roll, but I don't just want to roll the
die 100 times, I want to count how many sixes there are. So if the value is
six, I should increment the number of sixes, which means that I had to
initialize it, and at the time I had seen zero so far. But I better not do that
inside the loop because then I would reset it every time. Now after the loop
completes, I'll print out the number of sixes. If you run this you should get
17.